So, congratulations. You've built a web crawler. You've learned to
crawl. We're not quite at flying yet, but this is a
lot that you've learned in just three units. And by learning
about lists, we can build any other structure we want starting
from lists. And we'll see lots of other things that we
do in the next unit, as well as the units that
follow that. That use lists. We haven't quite finished building a
search engine. We have a way of getting a great start
towards our purpose, finding all these pages to crawl. What we
need in Unit Four is the way to get the content from
those pages, by starting from our seed page, and following the
crawl web procedure that you wrote. And then we'll use that to
build an index, so we can respond to queries when someone's
doing a search for a particular term. The other thing we'll do
in Unit Four is, we'll learn more about how the Internet and
the web work. I'm here with Anna Patterson who's built a bunch
of search engines, including building the world's
largest index of the web. And now
works for Google. And we've just finished building a very simple web crawler. I
want Anna to tell us something about how things are different if you want to
build a web crawler that works with the scale that Google has to deal with.
>> So there's three main issues with scaling up
a web crawler. One is the normal politeness that
you need on the Web. The second one is
how you get a bunch of machines involved in crawling,
not just one. And the last issue is how to consume a lot of bandwidth so
that you keep the expensive resource busy. While
still being polite. So, on politeness, there's a line
in the robots.txt that each domain tells you
how often you can crawl that domain. There's a
number of problems with that, which is that
multiple domains can be hosted with a hosted service,
and they can be hosted even on one machine.
So even though you're being polite to one domain, you're
really actually really hurting a hosting service, or you're hurting
a machine. So you have to make plans in order
to not hit one machine or one domain too
hard. The next thing is, that if you crawl on
just one machine. It, the state is very good, and
it's really easy to keep the state of the crawl
on the one machine. But then it's hard to
make a very big search engine, because you get as
much as one machine will crawl. So of course in
practice, you crawl on thousands of machines. Now, if you're
going to obey politeness, that means that each of your
thousand machines, needs to tell the other ones, what it
has crawled and what it's about to crawl and what
it, going to crawl in 20 minutes, right? All of this
communication overhead can actually slow down the crawler,
which actually hurts your aim of having a
big search engine. The last part is that
you want to max out your bandwidth. So one thing
that people do instead of trying to lessen
the communication, is they pre-process the corpus that
they already have. So when you've crawled a
set of pages you can process them and extract
out all the links that they point to. You can then normalize those links so
that Yahoo.com and dubdubdub.yahoo.com wind up being the
same string, and now you can farm those
strings out to your thousand machines, and
now they don't have to communicate because they
know they're not going to hit the same domain.
However, they could accidentally hit the same hosting
service and the same machine, but you can
take care of that ahead of time as well.
>> Thanks a lot Anna. I hope those of you who think about unleashing
your web crawler on the world, pay
careful attention to what she said about politeness.
>> Thank you for having me, and students, good luck on your search engines.
>> So I hope we'll see you back
soon. You'll have a homework for Unit three that's
going to be quite challenging, and I look
forward to seeing all of your answers to it.